it's great to welcome to the program
today Sheri Berman who's a professor of
political science at Barnard College at
Columbia University most recent book is
democracy and dictatorship in Europe
from the and I hope I'm pronouncing it
correctly the ancien régime to the
present days is that how it said that's
perfect good ok all right so let's so
let's jump right into it we've been
talking a lot about social democracy in
the context of what are the differences
between that and democratic socialism
how does this compare to different types
of capitalism and one of the interesting
areas of this is that much of sort of
modern social democracy socially
democratic thoughts stems from early
20th century Sweden and the Social
Democratic Party and if we look today at
Europe and what's going on that model
has actually changed significantly with
the rise in right-wing nationalism in
Europe and a lot of other changes that
are taking place so how would you if
someone just says to you you know sherry
how has the state of social democracy
changed over the last hundred years in
Europe how would you generally
characterize it well so there's lots of
different ways to answer that question
which is never a good answer to a
question I mean as far as the sort of
status of parties that call themselves
social democratic or would be seen as
kind of center-left we have seen a
dramatic decline in support for these
parties over the late 20th and early
21st century so one way to tell this
story is to talk about the rise of these
parties elect early politically during
the early 20th century they're sort of
greatest electoral success after the
Second World War and then a decline that
again has set in over the last decades
on the other way to tell the story is by
focusing less on how many votes they get
and more on their ideas and how powerful
those ideas have been the traditionally
are the sort of distinctive social
democratic view is one that accepts
capitalism but is wary of it and
believes that it is necessary for the
democratic state to intervene
in markets and in the economic sphere in
general to sort of protect citizens from
the most destructive and destabilizing
consequences of markets and again if
we're gonna look at it that way then one
could say starting in the 20th the
beginning of the 20th century Social
Democrats within the left started
fighting for this view against folks
further to the lapped Marxists
communists Democratic socialists only in
Scandinavia and particularly in Sweden
were these kinds of social democratic
views able to triumph on the left during
the interwar period but after the Second
World War these type of views come to
dominate mainstream center-left and
Social Democratic parties as well as by
the way most other parties in Europe on
the centre and center right so this
basic social democratic view that it was
the task of democratic states to control
capitalism to tour rather to tame
capitalism to protect citizens this was
basically accepted across the board in
Europe after the Second World War but by
the end of the 20th century this
consensus begins to fray and in fact
becomes largely replaced by a more
neoliberal consensus which reigns you
know sort of up through I would say the
financial and euro crisis and now we're
back again to an era when that consensus
that more neoliberal consensus is being
questioned and we're again debating some
fundamental questions about the
relationship between democracy and
capitalism the correct role and scope
for markets things of that nature
is there a phrase in a different way are
there places in Europe where as as a
sort of idea labeled as social democracy
many of those ideas are just sort of
mainstream and as such it's not as
important that they be labeled in that
way so when you look at for example the
healthcare systems of many European
countries the debate over well it's the
Social Democrats who want one type of
system and they're pushing against
everybody else who wants a sort of more
American
type system aren't a lot of those
institutions now just kind of part of
the baseline and as such they're no
longer labeled as socially democratic so
I think that's I mean that is absolutely
correct unlike in the United States
citizens in Europe since 1945 have come
to take for granted a whole range of
social protections that we are still
fighting over here in the United States
and you mentioned the most obvious ones
universal health care pre education a
whole variety of other social
protections that we do not have as a
matter of citizenship here in the u.s.
in that sense a sort of social
democratic view of the relationship
between states and markets still reigns
but these kinds of systems have come
under stress in Europe and they have
been cheap and they have changed fairly
dramatically over the past decade so
while you still have a very extensive
welfare state for example in Europe and
while in places like Sweden you know you
still have high levels of government
spending everybody expects health care
pensions education etc to be given as a
matter of course you have seen
significant privatization of many of
these policies you've seen rising
inequality and you've seen some
deterioration around the edge in the
kinds of commitments States have made to
citizens so yes um no in Europe it is
generally accepted that you know welfare
states are a good thing and that
governments do need to provide social
protection for citizens but there has
been an erosion of many of these
policies and more importantly perhaps
many of the principles upon which they
were predicated after the Second World
War so in any election there is always
what we would call some level of
defection people who in a primary vote
on one side and end up voting for in the
general election for someone from a
different party there's defection of all
kinds but we have some data specifically
that 12% of Boerne primary voters in
2016 ended up voting for Donald Trump
now they were you can argue balanced out
by some you know Ted Cruz voters who
ended up voting for Hillary Clinton but
to focus in specifically for the
purposes of our conversation on those
12% is that a phenomenon that is also
identifiable in Europe where European
Social Democrats and folks more aligned
with the ideology of Bernie Sanders gets
sort of swept up in some of these
populist right-wing movements are in the
nationalism and end up supporting that
or is that not a dynamic you've observed
in Europe so the answer to your question
again is yes and no okay I mean look at
any American election the candidate in
the primaries who what the supporters of
primary candidates who lose some
percentage of them always defect to the
other party so the 12% of Bernie Sanders
voters who defected to Trump is not out
of line with the number of Clinton
supporters who defected after Clinton
lost to Obama but the larger point that
you raise is a very important one the
defection of lower educated and
working-class white voters from the
Democratic Party to the Republican Party
and particularly to Trump in 2016 this
is a broader phenomenon that we have
seen in Europe in fact in many European
countries now it is not social
democratic parties but right-wing
populist parties that are the largest
working-class parties in their party
systems that is to say more workers
people in the working-class support
right-wing populist parties in many
European countries including France and
Austria than they do social democratic
parties so the broader phenomenon right
folks defecting from the left
particularly again among the
working-class and people with lower
educational levels to the populist right
this is a profoundly important and
destabilizing phenomenon that you can
see on both sides of the Atlantic in the
book sort of related to this one of the
things you talk about our countries in
Europe that have formed I guess what we
would call liberal Western democracies
in the last hundred several hundred
years and that at different points in
time and for different reasons there's
sort of a backsliding that happens
towards autocracy towards
authoritarianism what are the more
common reasons if there are unifying or
common reasons that that happen
there are they really unique cases well
there's lots of reasons why they happen
and I think it is important given how
worried we are about the state of
democracy today to point out that we
still have more democracies in the world
today than ever before and that we've
had less backsliding after the wave of
democratization that began in the late
20th century with the collapse of the
Soviet Union then we have during
previous democratic waves so those would
be waves in 1848 after the first world
war after the Second World War
so overall the state of democracy is
still quite strong but for countries
that do backslide in places where
democracy does decay if not collapse
there are definitely some patterns that
you know we should be wary of because in
the past they have led to again
significant problems with democracy
social polarization which of course is
something we are constantly talking
about here in the US this is very
problematic because it makes democracy
almost impossible to function people see
their opponents as illegitimate rather
than just as opponents they find it very
difficult to compromise in bargain which
of course is what democracy requires
every political battle becomes zero-sum
and so it's very difficult to have
well-functioning democracies in the
kinds of situations where you have
social polarization parties are pushed
further to the extreme that kind of
thing in general if we think about the
sort of period when democracy
quote-unquote work best in the West that
is to say after the Second World War
when we got stable well-functioning
democracies in Western Europe as well as
obviously well-functioning democracy
here in the United States we should also
remember that this was a period with
very particular social and economic
characteristics as well we had rising
growth Europe grew the fastest it's ever
grown in its entire history in the 30
years after 1945 and along with that
growth came incredible equalization of
incomes and wealth again greater
equalization that had ever occurred
before and this is important because it
helped to diminish divisions in society
it helped to create the sense that the
democratic system could deliver for
everyone that the gains of one group did
not
come at the expense of the others and
that politicians and parties were
responsive to the needs of their
citizens of course we all know that this
kind of these kinds of developments
change dramatically in the late 20th
century when growth slowed unemployment
rose particularly in Europe inequality
skyrocketed in the United States in
particular but in almost all European
countries as well and we began to see
again greater divisions within Western
societies all of which were accompanied
by dramatic social and demographic
change which only complicated the
process of democratic politics even more
absolutely fascinating stuff and I think
anybody who has listened to our
conversation can tell that there is a
lot to be gleaned from the history of
Europe in terms of what we are starting
to see in some ways in the United States
today the book is democracy and
dictatorship in Europe from the ancien
régime to the present day we've been
speaking with the book's author Barnard
College professor sherry Berman sherry
really a pleasure having you on thank
you so much I was really glad to have
this conversation